So we're going to do something
that looks really complicated,
something actually, if you talk
about maths, you go, oh,
no that looks horrific.
And then we'll see how it
turns out, all right?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yes.
We've done it.
That is probably the most
horrific equation we've ever
done on Numberphile.
But what does it mean?
Well, let's try this out.
We're going to plot it, right?
We're going to draw a graph
in my computer here.
And now, I'm going to
draw the graph.
And it should be-- let me make
that bigger for you-- it's the
equation Batman deserves, but
not one he needs right now.
Again, that is the
Batman curve.
It was famous when it went
viral last year.
A high school teacher designed
this curve, this equation, so
that it would draw
the Batman logo.
And he made it quite cleverly
out of different curves and
straight lines.
Can I show you how he did it?
So here we've got some things
that you may be familiar with.
Straight lines are quite
easy to draw.
What he did, though,
is we don't want
a circle for Batman.
We want an ellipse.
Has a slightly different
equation, so
it looks like that.
Now, he turned this into
his Batman wings.
Obviously, we don't want
the whole thing.
That's not what the
curve looked like.
He actually just used
these two ends.
He found a way to multiply his
equation, and the effect was
it hides some of the curve.
What happens here in this bit
that's missing, this becomes a
complex number, imaginary
number, which means
you can't draw it.
And that's what he did.
He just carried on doing that.
He just used curves and
straight lines.
And let me show you what they
look like to make his Batman.
Now, he used six curves.
Let's have a look at them.
So he used the ellipse.
And, oh, this is quite clever.
This is the bottom of
the Batman symbol.
And these straight lines and
these ones are going to form
his ears, very pointy
ones there.
And then, there you go,
some more curves.
That finishes off the picture.
You put it all together, and
that's what you get.
That's the Batman.
So he hid parts of it using
imaginary numbers, yeah, using
square roots, which would turn
some numbers that he doesn't
want to find into imaginary
numbers.
It was a very clever way.
He used the same curves, but
now you can see he's hidden
some parts of it.
You put those together, and
you put them together by
multiplying.
So he put it together.
He multiplied these equations
together.
What do you get?
The Batman curve.
It went viral last year, but I
wanted to do it, because I'm
very much looking forward to
the Dark Knight coming out,
Dark Knight Rises.